[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm rhett and i'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
i gotta talk to you about the trip that
i just got back from man i've been
spring breaking it
and i again i've been we got nothing to
talk about because you got back and i'm
like well i can't ask him about his trip
until now and now we have everything to
talk about what my trip to park city
utah did you have as much fun as you see
me projecting i did some uh i did i did
some mining
crypto
no
like uh you actually i don't know that's
the first thing i thought of when i
thought of utah and i didn't want to
make a mormon joke
was that like i don't know some sort of
precious precious gemstones medals i
think this happened there there's still
a lot of that happening yeah there i
don't know if you know this there's a
resurgence of the gold rush there in
utah i'm totally making that up is that
where we mined uh turquoise
utah that was nevada that was
nevada tonopah nevada for commercial
kings so yeah i'm going to give you
uh an update on my spring break
experience to
wet your appetite
wet i mean appetite i was on your own
spring break i was also here i know
because that's what i'm saying you have
not gone on your spring break i'm saying
while you were on your spring break i
was just here by myself yeah i don't
want to hear about that
unless unless something catastrophic
happened to the company which i assume
you would have already told me
and i was still following along on on
slack like i was i was lurking
in the in the emails and the slacks just
to make sure that like you were holding
things down and it seems that you did
yeah yeah i mean
i didn't i had nothing happen that is
worthy of talk talking about on your
biscuit so
the runway is clear not that anything
nothing happened right it stuff did
happen it's just not no i didn't work at
all oh
hey i mean i was just on me a little bit
you earned it you earned it man double
up
double up on the spring break i did work
but nothing interesting happened because
your spring break's
coming up
this recording my spring break might be
a two episode
oh yeah i don't know i don't know what's
gonna happen the fact that like
we call our kids spring break our spring
break because we do make it our spring
break i mean we have this luxury of
saying you know our schedule from a
production standpoint
is pretty much set up
over a year in advance
and we've learned as soon as like the
schools
publish what their
you know when the breaks are for the
kids
that we were able to block off some time
yeah we don't function like
a typical youtuber and every time we
interact with the typical youtuber about
like being on the show or doing
something together
we we it is a yeah a reminder of we
could have booked it what things are
like nine months ago without a schedule
like you're trying to book us um yeah
it's like trying to coordinate with
other people
is
that's one of the reasons that we
stopped interviewing people on the show
was because
well
they pretty much didn't schedule stuff
more than like a couple of weeks in
advance and then that like that
if you try to schedule it before that
it's like wow i have no clue what i'm
doing
right two months from now i'm like i
know what i'm doing
12 months from now
with no exaggeration like the things
that matter most that in terms of like
producing our ongoing content and then
there's like spaces that are left open
for stuff that we can slide in but right
when it comes to like vacations and
stuff like that and you got to
coordinate with multiple children good
groceries right
but it is kind of a luxury to be
able to say
hey we're going to kind of run this
year's schedule
through one of the grids being our kids
spring break so that it can be our own
spring break very nice
it's a very nice thing yeah
so we went to park city um because
i i let it be more of lincoln's decision
uh because when lily turned 16 years old
we had this idea
okay 16 is going to be a special year
uh we're going to take a trip with just
the 16 year old so lily wherever lily
wants to go we decided to go to lunch he
decided to go to london
i'm sure there's an ear biscuit about
that of course
lincoln turned 16 in the midst of the
pandemic he also turned 17. got nothing
so we're like hey you know it's like
you're you're you're um your 17 spring
break
you get to decide and he just said he
wanted to go skiing and i'm like oh yeah
okay i like this a little snow skiing
you're developing a hobby what if he had
a said water scheme an expensive one was
like how much our water skiing like how
would you how would you have been like
would you have redirected that we would
i think because your dad has a barefoot
water i would have gone
have you tried never tried the fact no
here's the thing barefoot water skiing
the fact that your dad has barefoot
water skied means that you probably have
the correct type of feet my foot is
nothing like my dad's but i think my
foot's better i have a flat i think flat
foot is perfect he's got a very archy
foot
yeah i didn't really ever thought i
could you know first of all i've never
seen a six foot seven person barefoot
ski but with an arch like yours i i
think that you've got like water skiing
feet i got ski features we should do
that we should bring back the vlogs and
link i'm definitely water skis i feel
like i could lose a toe or a nose
it's a dangerous sport
it'll daze you a little bit but you
can't get that hurt
okay so i i can walk you through the
experiences that
i had with my family and my dogs the
dogs are actually a big part of this
trip and so that was something that we
had to navigate so i i want to unpack
all that for you but something that's
top of mind for me that's not i don't
think it's related to the trip
maybe it will come back to be related um
i wanted to talk first just to kind of
give
more of
my anxiety assessment journey update at
the end of my spiritual deconstruction
episode thanks for the feedback on that
thanks for the feedback on all of our
episodes used hashtag air biscuits we
look at all those
i know a lot of you are talking about
how you really enjoyed getting to know
greg
the roommate little teaser there we're
definitely pulling together
um digitizing footage from the
archives never before seen except when
we showed it for a
a captive audience
in in a room the first comedy videos
that we ever made
that a lot of them did feature greg
about this
you don't understand
like i i had an idea that you had these
tapes
but
i just kind of forgotten like what's on
these tapes
all this just random footage of us in
our dorm room in our apartment with greg
with tim all the early videos we made
all the outtakes from the early videos
we made yes
so and i've only started scratching the
surface right of uh and just so you know
digitizing this stuff the only place
these are going to be available is the
mythical society
and
if you've if you're if you're not a
member of the mythical society now once
these things start rolling out i just
got to say after having watched a few of
them
yeah i'm like this might be the most
compelling thing that we've ever made
because it's just interesting to find
something from like 22 23 years ago
that was the very genesis of us
starting to try to be funny it's the
actual start of what we do now that no
one has ever seen except for one time
b be on a small group of friends
so
we're we're planning out how we want to
how we want to roll out these archives
and it needs to be on the mythical
society because
it's that's what the mythical society is
for that level of access there's also
some stuff some rights and licensing
issues that like otherwise we just
wouldn't be able to navigate
so uh
yeah that's that's a little teaser
because that's also top of mind for us
because we're looking at it but back to
the anxiety stuff
um yeah in the spiritual deconstruction
episode at the end i talked about how
at the top of the year
with christie's encouragement based on
conversations that i was also kind of
bouncing off you and and a few other
friends
uh deciding to not only get a new
therapist
but also
um
try out anxiety medication so i'm on
sertraline i've gone from 25 milligrams
to 50 milligrams
uh and it's since
january
and
going through this process i've i've
seen it as more of uh you know i've
my
my
level of observation of my own anxiety
has really gone up
you know because i'm
it feels kind of like an experiment like
okay now i'm i'm taking these pills
that
um you know i'm open to it i just and
you know people close to me
have had really good experiences and
then
it's it's it's had a positive impact on
their life so
it's i haven't had a stigma associated
with it i just never made the connection
that i personally needed it
but then i kind of got over that hump
that yeah i think
i think i could benefit from this i just
need to observe
what impact it's having
just to see
if this is a good choice for me
and then also if it is and i
i do believe that it is like i've
experienced positive benefits
what now is the like right dose how do i
dial that in
because
even like yesterday and this morning
especially this morning like i realized
i was like man i am so
anxious
i
um
and i do think i am more in tune with
how i'm feeling
uh like
my therapist is helping me like
observe more of the symptoms of
anxiety in my body like oh i feel a
little nauseous i feel a little tight
yesterday i by the end of the day i
realized
i would and when i got home i was like
you know what i'm just today was a tough
day i was just really angry
you know and it was like
and the frustrating thing is that like
i don't know why
like i i just start searching for the
thing that made me
angry and feel frustrated and it's like
i can't point to one thing it's like
nobody did anything to me
and then today it wasn't
and so it was one of those things it was
like i
i'm kind of ready for this day to end
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to bed at nine
o'clock you know which is only 20
minutes earlier than when my right i
might say that
right
and then did your music start playing
there was
yeah it starts playing
um
but then today it was like i just woke
up
anxious just like very on edge very
nervous not angry anymore not frustrated
but
i was just trying to figure out
what it was but then also
try to employ some techniques that i'm
learning to deal with it whether i know
the answer or not so like some breathing
techniques of like slow breathing in
like straw breathing where you
you breathe in slowly but then you
breathe out as if you're breathing
through a straw so that your out breath
is like longer than your in-breath gives
a signal to your body
that
you can calm down
um
but yeah it's
on one hand observing this is kind of a
good data point that like i'm on the
right track that like
all the things that i'm doing are
necessary for me
you know it's because this is a reminder
oh i've got this flare flare-up
of anxiety
and then i start to like try to figure
out what it is it's like well
i don't know exactly
what i don't i don't feel like i have
some amazing thing that i want to bring
to this episode and you know this is my
episode right i'm supposed to be you
expect me yeah like you're not preparing
anything
this is my trip i'm supposed to be
bringing something to this so that's the
first thing i point to is like
okay i get in my own head about
well i don't feel prepared
like this is one thing that really sets
off
anxiety for me is just not feeling
like i've got this like you don't have
this
and
that's kind of a theme
i think for me
that i realize over over many years
maybe over my entire life it's like okay
yeah this is a this is a legitimate
signal and symptom of anxiety that like
i just never labeled
so there's that and then i'm like you
know when we leave here
we're gonna go
and meet up with julian smith well
that's another teaser i'm full of
teasers today we reconnected with our
old friend julian i don't know i i guess
he's okay me teasing this but like we're
shooting something with him
it's his control whether it sees the
light of day
but uh
i i i think i found myself being very
keyed up about that
and i don't know why
you know it's like this should be
something that's it's fun to reconnect
but i feel like i mean
yeah i feel like it's very natural okay
like i
i
i don't know i mean
i feel like
the way that you're talking about it is
i'm anxious about these things and if i
was
normal i wouldn't be anxious about it
like i don't have a diagnosable anxiety
disorder
but
i get anxious about stuff all the time
that we're about to about to do in the
same way and it's i'll be like and and
and i'll i'll be driving home and i'll
be like
uh what is it what's going
why am i feeling this way and then i
like tried to find i'll try to find it i
try to get to the root of them but yeah
oh we're doing that thing and
yeah i don't feel prepared for it and i
bet you i'll feel better when it's over
and then
if if i'm right i will and then i
actually start fantasizing about it
being something that should be fun being
done and being over and being like and
then i'm gonna get home and i'm going to
eat dinner and i'm going to watch tv and
that won't be stressful yeah so i mean
i guess so i'm not i'm not dismissing
your anxiety i'm just saying this is
exactly it doesn't make you
weird i think it makes you normal
yeah i think this is exactly what i'm
trying to figure out because i've been
on
completely on that side of
on that perspective
on the outside of
i
i'll put it in the extreme an anxiety
diagnosis and saying for myself it's
like yeah i get stressed out stress is a
natural response to
um you know having having to step up and
when when when pressure hits you stress
is a good thing because it
it gets you ready
it's an it's a it's human
yeah it's not just
um
a problem something that should be uh
therapized or
uh
an anesthetized or however you want to
say it away so i'm like yeah it's of
course i get stressed out but then it's
like okay it gets to a level where you
have heart palpitations
sometimes you know they'll come and go
but like
okay that may be
that may have a an impact on my health
long term you know yeah and
um
but yeah that's how i've kind of i've
put it in this box of like well what you
just said
and now i've kind of switched over to
the other side it's like what if
yeah what is normal and what is more of
disordered level of
dealing with
anxiety well you know i think
my sort of
slightly informed but mostly
non-professional opinion
or perspective on
the like an anxiety disorder is
when you have an anxiety disorder
a lot of times it will be there's a
baseline of anxiety and then you'll kind
of begin filling it with things that you
could be anxious about so it's almost
like the anxiety starts and then the
events or the circumstances fill it
versus
a more normal response to is an event
makes you you become anxious about
something now obviously if you become
anxious about it to a extreme degree
that like affects your functioning and
your health and that's extreme but it's
almost like people people who are you
know deal with depression
they wake up in the morning and they
feel depressed not because they had a
bad day or not because they're
anticipating having a bad day but
there's something in the chemical
makeup of their brain that just be
giving them the blues giving them a
feeling of depression and then you start
trying to connect it to like is it for
this or is it that oh no it might just
be a brain thing and
there could be treatment for that
so
what you're describing is a bucket
of that i need to that
i could fill with something to always
have an object of my anxiety
because you feel like your baseline
anxiety has changed after being on
this medication for three months
because at this point it should have
kicked in yeah right yeah uh
it has
but i think what's happened is you know
i could add other things to the list
it's like okay christy gave me a report
about a conversation she had with my mom
about you know louis
you know having another stroke
and then you know
i got a friend that i want to have a
conversation with
that
the friend's not is going through
something that like
i haven't been able to have that
conversation so there's like
there's some energy going out in that
direction and so there's this cumulative
effect of
okay that then i wake up and i just feel
like in a knot you know
and
so it's
and honestly i kind of thought
uh
because i've been experiencing some the
benefits of the medication
and the therapy everything that
at you know it was it's a bit
discouraging to find that like okay now
that these things have piled on
it it kind of feels like i'm back where
i was at least yesterday and today you
know so it's
then you start to think about well does
that mean
should i consider upping the medication
i'm still in that zone where i'm trying
to dial that in
i think what i'm concluding even in this
conversation is that like okay let me
see if if this wave passes if the
baseline is still and i'll also i'll
also talk to my doctor again my
therapist yeah yeah all right your
doctor
in terms of your biscuits i you don't
have to give me advice on that front oh
don't worry they will
but um yeah i'll also i have a follow-up
schedule with my doctor and i'm you know
i'm talking to my therapist tonight
but i'm just kind of sharing just the
the
what's at work in assessing
uh
my anxiety and kind of
getting comfortable with the fact that
like i am treating it and i am talking
about it
um yeah
uh
and i'm not talking about getting
comfortable talking about it publicly
just
wrapping my mind around in all
conversations that like hey this is a
this is a part of
what i'm what i'm dealing with
and
i'm i'm coming to grips with it and i'm
i'm still developing a game plan and i'm
just observing
and i find that i'm observing things
more closely than i never did so it's
like the more things that come up it's
like oh yeah that's been something
that's been true of me
for
my entire life
now i'm seeing it through a different
lens of of treatment
and it is very helpful and it's so i do
feel very positive about it overall it's
just the past few days it's been more of
a
uh
a dip a dip
and we are you know
we are getting
back into yeah a more stressful
schedule i i i was thinking about this
other night
there were there was like two weeks in a
row
where almost every night
i had some commitment
yeah now some of it was like fun stuff
like oh we're going to a concert or
we've got our date night scheduled
but other nights there were like some
social engagement or
and i was just like man this is the
world opening back up is absolutely
so there's that
there's a little there's less of this
little respite in the evening
it's like getting home at
10 30 11 11 30. it's a lifestyle shift
yeah
and and realizing that this is what my
life used to be like and the other thing
is
you know
we've always had a lot going on but
there's a lot of things getting to a
stage where they're taking
more time i mean
or just feeling like what with all these
irons in the fire which which one's
gonna catch the oven mitt when i'm not
looking
yeah yeah yeah so i mean i've definitely
been feeling that
i mean that's what i talked to
my therapist about
last week is just like
i'm kind of beginning to
feel like the the pressure is increasing
it's been you know as difficult as the
pandemic was in many many other ways
the one
positive thing about it was
there's a lot it seemed like there was a
little less pressure in in some ways
there's there was less
demands on our time
and that's kind of reversing so i i mean
i'm not surprised that you're fee that
you're feeling
you know
that you're feeling a little bit of uh
that the anxiety is like getting a
little prickly you know what i think i
need a little bit i think i need a
vacation i think i need a spring break
yeah that is interesting because you
just got back from the vacation i do
think that's also a factor is like
yesterday was my first day back so it's
vacations
vacations tend to make us anxious
because yep you're like well what did i
fall behind on definitely felt felt some
of that so
yeah i think
you know i'm gonna be in observation
mode at least for another week coming
out of this
and but before i'm like making any
decisions about
changing my approach because i do feel
very good and still
mostly excited about
and confirmed about being on the right
tracks for
um for what i'm doing here
but but but yeah i wouldn't uh i'd i'd
love to go back to park city let's
switch to that
but first let's get
some promo in for our our uh our boy boy
trevor's podcast trevor talks too much
you know mythical kitchen trevor uh he's
a uh you know he's really good at making
pastries you know that looks good
he's good at making conversation he's
good at making a lot of things but he's
like got some like special high high
dollar training in that pastry area i
think
you know we're trying to be building up
that he doesn't do that on the podcast
podcast but if but if you like the idea
of somebody being really good at
pastries and also really good just
talking to somebody yeah yeah i mean the
t the tlc that goes into a pastry a
perfect pastry is very similar to the
dlc that goes into a perfect episode of
a podcast okay you know you gotta you
gotta fold that croissant yeah you have
many layers
um
he brings in guests that
you know for me that it's bringing a
fresh perspective into my world
yeah through trevor's perspective mxm
tune she's an artist that i when we
pulled up her music videos like oh she
is yeah she's got something i like her
style so listen to that conversation uh
knowing eubanks is a gamer
check out
check out that one and the talibee twins
are coming on um very soon
if not already yeah so he's getting in
the mix man he's driving the mix trevor
toss too much
um it's a fun lesson
learn something if you're into these
people that he's having on there great
and if you're not you should
expand your world well yeah if you're an
oldie like us and you want to feel a
little bit blessed just come out and say
yeah
um
of course we've been to park city
a number of times uh
park city is known for being the venue
for the sundance film festival
towards the top of every year and so we
found ourselves at the sundance film
festival
in in str in all like tertiary
capacities we were there with uh
um
we were making videos like with cadillac
we were like interviewing celebrities
about cadillac's you can go back on the
rent and link channel check that out we
went um
we were guests of youtube a couple of
times like
they they had like a
lounge
so we did some q and a's and stuff like
that and saw a few documentaries when we
were there
but and then we would like maybe ski for
a few hours
and then sometimes we would see our
friend eric
who
um our high school friend who was
uh one of the guitarists and the wax
paper dogs
eric's lived there for like
20 years now
he's like worked in and around the the
mountain resorts doing like
high high up technology stuff
he started as a snowmaker so yeah i got
to reconnect with eric got to hang out
with him so i'm like he was
he you know he he definitely wanted to
like say oh you should do this you
should go here he was like a he was like
a sherpa well he was like ski patrol at
some point i think right
in the early days
he just told me he was a snow maker and
then he went into like the i.t
department but he knows he knows all the
he knows the mountains the thing that i
remember
and i didn't bring it up this time
because uh i just didn't want to rehash
the story with him again but i'll do it
here
when we went to sundance that one time
and we went
we were
we had some drinks
and i think i'm going to say a
combination of the altitude
and not being acclimated to that
and having a few too many drinks for
that particular environment
i woke up the next morning we were like
before we leave town we got eric we got
to meet you we're going to meet you for
for breakfast
and he like
so we met him at this breakfast place
and
i i've not been hungover
often in my life
okay there was the one time in high
school
that i told the story
uh
and then there was
i mean there's sometimes you like wake
up with a headache but like like
i've never woken up and before my eyes
are open
the i could tell that the room is
spinning oh
except like a couple of times like i
once you experience that once it takes
me like 10 15 years before i forget
apparently that i never want to feel
that again and i think the timing worked
out just right that like oh my gosh i
woke up
the room was spinning then i opened my
eyes i was like yep i don't am i going
to be able to get out of bed it was bad
and i i i remember this yes you do
because i was wearing sunglasses and i
was like dude i don't feel good and we
got a like an uber to the breakfast
place to meet eric
and i didn't tell eric that i felt bad i
just wore my sunglasses the whole time
it was very bright
and we were like wearing these heavy
coats because it was like snowy outside
and then we go inside and it's like
baking hot
and the sun is baking through the window
and shining right in my eyes which is
she goes at least gave me a reason to
wear the sunglasses
and you're also a sundance and makes you
look like you're somebody if you've got
some weddings like doing that like
hangover sweat
and like we're talking to eric and we're
like catching up and like i was trying
to like
convey that i was so happy to see him
because it had been a while
and then i just let the two of you do
most of the talking while i just sat
there and like i was looking at the menu
and i remember that the mit like the
menu made me nauseous
and then eric ordered one of those egg
benedict things where it's like
you poke the egg and it
oozes out like yeah like a properly made
egg something that like an emt should be
like working on in the back of an
ambulance
oh my gosh it's like or like an eye
surgeon or something
yeah you've just described the properly
made thanks benedict
and i remember looking at that and i was
like
i need to go to the restroom and i went
to the bathroom you remember this i'm
kind of beginning to piece together
and i was i was about to vomit at the
table and then i'm like shimmying to the
bathroom
and i've and i got to the bathroom and i
started when i saw the toilet i just
started vomiting you know
before i got to the toilet why didn't
you feel like you could tell him that
you were hungry i don't know
because i was embarrassed
it's so dumb
like i think it was in that weird zone
where it was like
uh
it might have been a little
holier-than-thou thing
i don't think so though there's no way
that could have been it was that the
cadillac year
yes i think it
that might have been it would have been
if it was back then that might have been
first time we went to sundance
yeah because that was like
2008 pre-deconstruction
pre-deconstruction and we were like
trying to be these like
we wanted to keep up appearances you
can't let them know you're hungover
because god will
be upset with you
i just think i was embarrassed i don't
know how spiritual it was but like i had
a lot of cleaning up to do in the
bathroom oh because
i did you know i'm like taking all the
paper towels and like trying to mop up
the so you missed the toilet yeah man
i i missed the floor
i like hit the wall a little went out
the window
hit the wall it's like you ever been in
the bathroom and you're like who
exploded how do you explode everywhere
well i understand and i do i still don't
know the answer to that for poop because
i've seen that i understand the vomit
but i don't understand the diarrhea
explosion in a bathroom man i'm like
like it like i'm all like
i'm so curious i would be willing to be
there to see it happen like it's the
nastiest thing but i'm just so curious
i'm like what what what position were
they in
so every time i get together i mean like
i mopped everything up because i was not
going to leave that for the employees
but it took me a long time to come back
out when i came back out i think it was
like guys i'm just
i've had a i've had a rough time in the
restroom and i'm still having a rough
time out here i'm glad you're finished
with your your bursted eyeball egg
your poached eggs so that's what i think
about every time i
i i go back to
park city and especially when we see
eric but um you have like a pavlovian
vomit response to air no it's no no it's
not bad good good
the main thing i i booked at airbnb and
i was like every time
since
i think since we first got jade i was
like
we're gonna take this dog we're going to
fly with this dog i've seen people do it
we're going to get we're going to take
jade home with us i love jade she's a
member of the family i want her to be
with me
but we never did it like it's you know
you you gets down to it and you're
always like
it's it's not worth it it's probably
it's probably tough on jade it's like
she likes the
the the kennel we take her to it's
called a freaking pet resort
yeah you know
they they sleep on beds it's like they
got like
webcams you can see them at all times
yeah it's pretty nice it's great barbara
loves it it's redonkulous
and barbara's there
usually at the same time so we always
talked ourselves out of it but i was
like christy now that you're so attached
to jasper or at least that's what i was
thinking now that she's so attached to
jasper i'm like
this is a this is we're gonna do it this
time like we've taken road trips like
when we went to sedona we took the cats
the dog and the cat right when we got
the cat which was crazy
um so it's not that we haven't gone on
trips with the dogs like if we do on
like a beach trip or something but
they've never flown with us
so i'm like
uh park city this is a very short flight
it's like around an hour
it's like this is a good
test and plus me
lincoln and lando are going to be skiing
christy you're going to be back at the
airbnb
just chilling out doing what you want to
do this is what she she was looking
forward to that but i was like don't you
want don't you want your little furries
with you
your animals don't you want your doggies
i was like let's do this
so she said yes
uh and it was really because she's so
attached to jasper like
oh my gosh it's like he's like a little
baby to her he does better at the uh
the kennel now though right i mean yeah
because because i picked him in jail
right
and post it on your instagram i mean and
he did like have like a he's so he's
very clingy but he's gotten better like
he has he had separation anxiety didn't
seem super traumatized when i picked him
up yeah he's lived with us for a year
now and he's uh so he's
he's doing so much better
on that front so that really wasn't a
factor
so um
i mean with delta at least you got to go
to a special counter
when you get there and yeah we had the
like the little carriers that are like
delta approved it's like okay if i buy
this one i know it will fit under the
seat in front of me and
like because the last thing i wanted to
be turned away because my like carrier
was too big
so like we got all that squared away uh
we even the weeks leading up to it i was
like all right christy we're gonna put
the dogs in the kennel and we're gonna
walk them around i think i'm gonna take
them
downtown take them into town not
downtown l.a but like take them into
town
um like around the shops area and just
like carry them in the carrier both of
them both of them just to like
get them
acclimated to being in a carried in a
carrier right
and uh because she laughed in my face
just like you did just now i didn't do
that
but i didn't think it was that weird to
carry two dogs in a carrier
i think you got to get them used to in
like a bustling little little shopping
area yeah i was just like a man carrying
two dogs
i mean
that guy's that guy's going somewhere
typically you would walk your dog in a
shopping area
not carry them in a in a car head in or
head out
i didn't do it but around the house i
would do it and i put their head in yeah
and then we got there
and um
you got to go to a special counter
because you got to pay a fee for this
it's like it's like 150
per dog one way it's another passenger
man it's probably actually a good deal
it's not real it's not another seat yeah
but it's i mean people's dogs create
issues for other people you can't you
have to discourage it a little bit you
got to discourage it a little bit you
gotta you you gotta put in a speed bump
people are willing to pay like for us
six hundred dollars round trip every
once in a while that dog's gonna
take a crap inside the kennel people are
gonna smell it and you gotta discourage
it you gotta discourage it you're right
so we get there to the curbside and i
asked the guy was like uh
we have dogs we never travel with dogs i
think we have to go to special counties
like follow me so he takes us around
this a decent sized line and then like
he skips the line goes and talks to one
of the agents whispers and then points
at us and like stands us kind of to the
side in front of the line this is
checking in and checking in and then the
guy leaves and i like i gave him a tip
because the dude just like escorted us
to skip the entire line i was a little
self-conscious about that i'm really
nervous about having these dogs and then
jasper from within the crate thingy the
carrier sees another dog and we're
standing in front of everybody that's
trouble and he barks twice
two barks really two bars just two just
two
and then all of a sudden i see from a
long ways down there's like one two
three four five six seven agents behind
and then way down there this woman just
starts huffing and puffing
down behind everybody maybe she's a
manager of some sort comes all the way
around and goes up to christy because
christy was holding jasper's carrier
says ma'am
if you don't get your dog to start
barking
you're gonna have to take him out of
here
i'm like what
i'm like he barked
twice just two barks and i'm like what's
this isn't it this is an employee the
employee i'm like man this is intense
i'm about to i'm about to shell out the
dough come on and you were thinking i'm
jasper yeah twice it would get a lot
worse than this that and this was the
main thing i was worried about
so then i like i'm like crap i was like
okay we will we'll do what we can
thinking
i don't know what we're gonna do
but then i took off my jacket and i just
draped it over the whole thing where he
couldn't see anything alligator mode i
yeah
and i thought he was i thought that
would just make him freak out more but
it actually didn't it worked
i don't know i would not have predicted
it would have worked or i would have
done that to start with
but yeah it that definitely worked the
um and then
we take them through security i'm having
to google like all this stuff like
you you put the dog through the thing if
you do does it fry them
you don't want to put them in like when
you cook a dog in it well it wouldn't
cook them but the effects would show up
later delayed delayed it's an x-ray yeah
i mean dogs get x-rayed all the time not
at that level yeah
i took the dog out of the carrier held
jade in my arms and uh jasper and
chrissy's arms and we walk them through
and then put them back in the carrier
by that point they do a cavity search of
either of the dogs uh
no
good
not of me either
a little disappointed i'm still waiting
for that
um
well you got to store something up your
butthole they ended up doing really well
on the flight uh the vet had given
christy a sedative for the dogs
which uh
the vag giving christy a sedative
so she was okay
christie has her own
version of a sedative
uh
because she has uh
a pronounced fear of flying who did the
dogs
help create a distraction for her that
made her less focused not on the first
flight because we were so keyed up about
what's
everything was new and we were worried
about all of the logistics that i'm
telling you about so it was like we were
pretty we're pretty on edge for that
reason
um but we get them on the plane we put
them underneath the seat in front and
then they're uh
they did they did great by the time we
got off the plane we were like
um
unzipping the top and walking down to
baggage claim like their heads are
sticking out
and it's like all of a sudden this is
feeling
we're feeling like those people so they
didn't bark at all on the plane they did
not bark it all on the plane after we
took off
um
i asked the woman next to me well i'll
tell that story in a second after we
took off
they eventually got up and got in our
laps i mean they're little cat dogs they
just want to be in our laps and once
they're in our laps they're like they
just sleep
jasper looked out the window a little
bit but like
not a peep out of them
they they did abs they were like docile
the
the sedative had an effect on jasper he
was really sleepy but it really didn't
have an effect on jade she didn't
she didn't sleep any and i was also
concerned about them using the bathroom
but like
we made sure they went right before we
left the house and then
they didn't
there's like pet
pee and poop areas designated in airport
terminals oh but not on the plane no not
on the plane on the turn in the
terminals but we didn't want to take
them in there and they were fine they
didn't have to use the bathroom until we
got to where we were going what but what
about short flight a cross-country
flight because i'm thinking about doing
this with barbara uh you have to look
into it like i think cross-country
flight you can do it i've seen dogs um
but if like if you're flying to hawaii i
i think i read that you have to put the
dogs you have to check the dogs which is
not something i would want to do they
have to go in the luggage thing i don't
know exactly where they go they can't go
in the luggage thing it gets too cold
it's not pressure regularly they go they
i don't know exactly where they go i
just i don't want to find out but i
don't want to put my dogs in there i
just wouldn't take them
um there's the emotional support route
which i can i'll get to that in a second
but
i mean pulling out the knowing that we
wanted to pull out the dogs on the
return flight i i turned to the woman
next to me
when we first sat down because i was
like
how are you with dogs
because you don't want to freak somebody
out which is what i think that
the manager who is freaking out was like
you got to do something about your dog
barking because some people freak out
some people are afraid of dogs right and
it's like you gotta the people take
precedent over the dogs if you can't
control your dog
then hey you lose customers you get to
lose customers
so i was trying to be
uh
sensitive to this passenger who was
sitting next to me on the flight she was
like oh i love dogs so then we pulled
out our dogs a little bit later and she
was happy and then
she pulls out her phone and she shows us
a picture of her dog
but it's a selfie
of her
with her dog i'm like oh you got a cute
dog you you are a dog person when i
looked at the picture
it was a bit strange because
um
the the woman
the picture she showed me it
she had applied that face filter to her
face
and i just don't get it like a face tune
yeah like a face tune where it's like it
makes your face like it looks like
really smooth like you have on makeup
right i mean she had on some makeup in
real life and like i'm sitting right
next to her but it's like that is not i
can tell it's you but it's not you
it's like the emoji version of you it's
like this is obviously a fake you you've
put a filter on yourself it's just
i don't know the whole thing is just
strange to me yeah a lot of people do
you know and i of course i see all the
people on tik tok that are like
this is not my face
this is not my face yeah but they're at
least drawing attention to it yeah at
least they're drawing attention to it
but it gets stranger when a stranger is
showing you this picture
usually you see this person like
on facebook right and there's
on a plane
showing you the picture and the phone's
not right next to their face right
that's that's the issue what made it
even weirder
was again the whole point is that the
dogs in the selfie too
and the face filter was applied to the
dog too
did you know that could happen
the dog's face was like
super smooth altered the only puppy no
the only thing i could really tell was
that the left eye of the dog it was like
a chihuahua the left eye of this
chihuahua was like darkened and
bigger it was like the shadow on the
left side of the dog's face was
interpreted by the filter as part of the
dog's eye so the left eye the dog was
like twice as wide
as the right eye of the dog and this
woman thought that was cute i think
i don't i don't know why she showed are
you sure it just wasn't a big-eyed
chihuahua well i didn't want to ask at
that point because then i'd be like and
is that what your face normally looks
like because i think that's a special
breed i think i saw that one big left
eyed chihuahua yeah that's specific yeah
it's a little asymmetrical the face
smoothing didn't know what to do with
that dog's eye
do you think she hasn't looked at the
dog she's showing the pictures she's her
dog
yeah
i just think that people are kind of
blind to like how strange the filter
like it's like you can't see how obvious
it is but if you're looking at your i'm
gonna find a picture of my dog to show
to strangers when they ask oh that's a
cute one
don't you you're you're looking at the
dog this is weird it's so weird
but to me maybe you were actually the
victim of an internet prank video and
you didn't respond sincere it was
to me it just highlights the
the problem like the the
just how these face filters have just
fooled people
like well they haven't fooled many
people people no but the people who use
them think they're fooling people and
i'm not talking about the ones that are
like this is not my face some of them
are real crazy
it's amazing how much with nothing to
compare it to you're like oh that
person's gone through like i'm like a uh
makeup makeover it's like very extreme
and model-ish but it is realistic like
the technology is getting amazing but
the one that people normally use like
for the past
year or two on i guess facebook or
whatever instagram
it's very obvious that you're applying
this filter
to everybody except the person who's
applying the filter i think you lose
perspective you lose perspective on it
and it's a it's a problem
it's i mean what are you gonna do about
it
i think it's gonna become my thing
like
i'm a crusade against face filters i
mean obviously it's like
it it just seems dysfunctional right
uh
yeah well you know it is a
and if you're fooled to the point where
you're putting a dog in it
i wonder if the if the idea is okay so
obviously we all do
some sort of
altering of our face or whatever like
when we shoot things on video we we just
so we're not a couple of shiny boys
yeah we put some makeup on i'll put in
some eye drops because i have
perpetually bloodshot eyes and
everyone's like he's always high
and i'm like no i just have bloodshot
eyes and i have to put in so i do some
artificial things to my face to make
myself more presentable right yeah yeah
um are you you're of course saying
you're on a slippery slope into face
filtering no i'm saying and culturally
yeah uh and traditionally women are more
apt to do more things to their face with
makeup than men are that's changing a
little bit but like that is sort of
you know the norm in the past
um
and then it's like
and you know when somebody's got makeup
on like so if someone shows up and
they've got makeup on that like it's
decorative in some way it's like oh
there's a different color over this
person's eyes
we've kind of accepted that
maybe the people who are doing face
filters are like i'm not trying to fool
you i i know that it's obvious that i
have a face filter but this is the face
that i want to show you this is the face
of my little dog that i want to show you
i want the big guy the big eye thing
because i think this is cute it's a it's
a leap from wearing makeup to face i
agree i i i i don't believe that's
what's happening i i think what's
happening is i'm sure there's another
perspective i think what you're doing
here and i really appreciate it yes
because we don't have a strong point of
view i'm just trying to figure it out is
that we know we're going to get some
sort of comment that has
it presents a different perspective
that's that might have to lead to an
apology that's the world we live in
on our podcast in on the internet right
i don't want to offend anybody who uses
a face filter but at the same time and
so when i say something like is this a
sign of dysfunction it's like okay
is that a line that i can't cross
conversationally
because someone's going to come out of
the woodwork and say well have you
thought about it this way it's like okay
yeah obviously people have a right to
put on a face filter i just don't
understand it and i'm not saying it's
dysfunction i'm asking a question
now i'm being so defensive well i mean
when i see when i see it so don't get it
there and it you know it happens it's
like
and again i don't go on facebook and my
wife doesn't go on facebook because
you know in many ways instagram too
though yeah i know but i feel like
facebook is the place
where you just i feel like it's more
prominent there because facebook and the
people who use facebook maybe
in instead of instagram right which is a
certain
genre or a certain sort of generation
even
i think that i think they're on facebook
are more likely to not realize that it's
obvious they're using people who use
facebook as their primary social media
are less technically savvy than people
who don't
that's a generalization that i'm willing
to make right you made it uh and i think
that it's just like it's like when your
mom goes on facebook and sends a message
to you like call me immediately but she
makes it her like status update
you know like that kind of stuff happens
all the time
call brian call me immediately and this
is like her like best friend has liked
it yes brian do that
that mom is and or dad i'm not trying to
say it's women i'm saying moms and dads
uh
and parents of all kinds
um
are probably more likely to use a face
filter in a way that they did not
they lost perspective at some place
along the way and so when i see it i
don't because it's different than
getting plastic surgery you talk about
makeup but then you've got okay if you
got if you got lip plumpification or i
don't know you've got the hot you got
the cheek implants whatever you got i
don't know
i don't care it's fine you know it's i
do feel like this is different because
it's like
i don't know
it's a different thing i like if i
couldn't grow a beard
i would consider getting a chin implant
but you wouldn't consider honestly
applying a a beard filter to all of your
pictures no but i grow a beard as a
filter
what my beard is a filter
i mean it's natural it grows naturally
so i guess cutting it would be to do
going against nature but i'm just saying
that like but you wouldn't walk around
well i mean like a beard toupee does
that exist by the way i'm sure like yeah
if it can be conceptualized it can be
invented yeah i mean sure people people
have beard toupees
beard pages i'm saying i agree with you
when i see somebody who's done a face
filter i think this person has identity
issues that's what i think that's my
knee-jerk reaction but then i when i've
turned that lens back on myself i'm like
well you got identity issues as well
sure but you're just being a little bit
more savvy in the way that you're
addressing them i
i mean you might have more i more
self-consciousness than someone who's
willing to use a face footer it's like
hey
i want to share this picture but i don't
want to i don't want to put on makeup to
take a picture i'm just going to put
this face filter on and then i'm going
to post that picture it's like
so what who cares i know it's to me it
comes down to do you know that people
know it's a face filter it's like do you
know that people know are you okay with
people knowing that this is a face
filter are you okay with people knowing
you were wearing makeup are you okay i
think people are knowing people who use
it don't you that you have plastic
surgery i think it's
maybe that's what i'm addressing well i
saw one where it was the whole they had
done the whole family
because the thing that happened
sometimes it was like dog in the photo
because they don't know that
is the thing you see sometimes is one
person who is the person whose account
it is
they've done the facetune filter to just
themselves so let's just say
it's a person in the family and in the
other the spouse and the kids don't have
it done then it's especially evident
oh you can do that you can just circle
one election
but then one time i saw a family where i
guess in an effort to disguise yes they
had done everyone including the
[Laughter]
it children like this is a family of
angels this is great
yeah it's just it i mean and then you
know the i mean if that's a teenager
talk about crin
i can't take this photo down i don't
know how to do it
oh man
this should have been the whole episode
because i feel like we're really getting
into something important yeah you
haven't even talked about your damn trip
yet i'm talking about the most important
part flying there with my dogs
what about skiing man face filtering the
dogs um
all right i guess we can come back let
us know what you think about face
filters that's what we do need to
hashtag ear biscuits about okay
but we
and we can we can do a follow-up on this
we can do an entire expose maybe or
maybe we'll just start applying the face
filter to our face
i finally got to park city
the dogs were there
it was
let me finish the dog part i think that
it was
all right
that's really what i wanted to talk
about the most anyway apparently
um
we were very glad that we brought the
dogs we had this like collapsible
um kennel that would keep both the dogs
that like i could carry in my suitcase
um so when we left the house they didn't
just like
potentially pee or poop anywhere uh we
also had to pay a fee at the airbnb for
the dog but still it was not as much as
the
keeping them in the kennel in the pet
resort
uh
really self-conscious about saying i
take my dogs to a pet resort but i'm
also very proud of it
um
so that was a good choice on the way
back we were much more at ease knowing
the effect that the
the sedative would have on jasper and
like covering the crate like we started
to get things down
that to the point where christy was
talking about we're walking in the
airport on the way back the dog's heads
are sticking out and people are like
look pointing and whispering to other
people about the cuteness of our dogs
and christie and i are looking at each
other and like just talking about how
we're those people that we've always
been jealous of at the airport really
yes because they have their dogs and we
don't have our dogs and here we are
being we have our dogs what is it about
the dogs about or about you
oh it's definitely about the dogs are
for me
and again that that gets to the
the emotional support of the dog
clicking into place it's like
christie experienced it firsthand with
like her
uh fear of flying i was like is having
jasper helping you know petting a dog
releases endorphins yeah it has and then
having somebody that you're caring for
what about petting a dolphin
uh
yeah promotional support no it releases
in dolphins
[Laughter]
that's not how baby dolphins are made
sorry releasing in dolphins
i mean that might work on a t-shirt but
you're in dad job should i tweet that no
emotional support no because you don't
want to tweet about emotional support
stuff and
oh yeah yeah i would i would find a
different way we've uh we've we've dug
too much of a hole up talking about like
women wearing makeup today right and men
yeah yeah and all people yeah yeah damn
whatever
okay um so yeah i'm like
i think we've backed into a legitimate
case for jasper becoming an emotional
support dog and then i don't think i
have to pay 150 each way
and i don't think i have to put him in a
kennel
but
i mean she's got to give him a little
jacket
yeah that's great right
yeah but i didn't want to be that person
you can get an emotional support
certification
probably
for squirrely reasons
i've been told
but i didn't want to do that yeah that's
why no one's going to like i didn't say
no i did not want to abuse that system
but now i find that like but it might be
legitimate christie might be a
legitimate candidate and then it's like
we might need to grandfather
me and jayden
question it definitely helped her
and it it helped me too like i didn't i
would take jade everywhere if i could
but she should be here right now but the
circumstances of this trip
uh lent themselves to
[Music]
them not being an inconvenience
um but like let's just say you decided
hey family trip to france i don't yeah
especially when you don't have a home
base that you're that someone is there
most of the time like everything kind of
lined up so it's still it's just a trip
yeah yeah but i was making the argument
when we go back home and we stay in an
airbnb
we can take the dogs to visit our family
and i think they'll be fine
so i'm lobbying for that to be the next
thing yeah yeah for christmas we'll
bring in the dog's house our plan is
what's that barbara because we're going
to north carolina in the summer
um and we'll be staying at the
pla you know the place that we bought
there
and
um for maybe longer than a week the it
might be two but the plan is to take
barbara for that trip i think i think
barbara will do fine on the plane it's
the only thing that's gonna be a problem
is
she likes people and food so much that
she may start whining the vet the vet
can give her the sedative and and they
said that we could give jasper another
one if he needed but other than that if
i did not have a home base
no
it's just such an inconvenience and
barbara loves going to the pet resort is
what she tells me every time she gets
back i'm sure she does she's like you
look on the webcam i'm really bonded
with those [ __ ] this time
yeah
a few of them use the face filter yeah
right i don't know about i don't know
about those ones with identity issues
but
um
okay the the park city skiing it of it
all i you know it i didn't have
it there's not any like huge thing i
wanted to tell you about but how hard
did you go and you skied instead of
snowboarded i skied um we went park city
and canyon resorts are now combined to
be like a large super large the largest
ski resort in the lower 48. we also went
to a third or all resort called deer
valley which was just like another
seven minutes
beyond
we i we had never skied deer valley i
don't think
no snowboarders are allowed there
um the thing about deer valley and uh
park city canyons not so much
was that
if you want to ride greens
i guess i'm not snowboarding so i won't
say ride ski greens which
lincoln and i could do some blues
but we're still getting our bearing with
skiing and lando
is not ready for blues
um
now after being there for three days or
before even now
you know
it's um talk about anxiety like the
mixture of bringing anxiety to the
slopes is like is a big test and of
course you know he he deals with anxiety
too so does lily and like lily learn how
to ski but then she was like it just it
makes me really anxious to like be going
down a mountain on these like
fl
flat wooden things you know it's like
shoes and wood skis
well that's our problem
well i guess they're not going to the
90s
okay
uh
my papa had wooden water skis that's
what i was thinking about like the ones
that are hanging up on the gmm set
um
but lando when we eased him into it he
did really well and it was so it was
just test of anxiety of like okay being
in a comfort zone you know if you so no
i did not push myself i made a decision
it's like
i want to enjoy myself and you know i
don't want to hurt myself
that's the only thing i hate most of the
time the thing about the greens there
unlike definitely big bear even mammoth
is that like you got like the lower part
where you got the greens and then you
keep going up the mountain and it gets
like it gets more complex and like black
diamond as you go
higher elevation well that's not really
the case at park city there are way you
can go all the way to the top
and definitely at deer valley you can go
all the way to the top and then ski
greens
all the way down so it's like you can do
these like really long runs
and i was able to take lando all the way
up there
and really enjoy it just like kind of
take out time do some do some carving it
was warm too it was nice i mean so the
snow wasn't great but
we don't care it's like i'll drink any
red wine you know i'll ski any slope
especially if like if you can buy those
if it's not absolutely frigid yeah i'm
not drinking drinking wine but on the
subs but we had
so we had a really good experience
um
leno didn't have the endurance or the
just the appetite to stay as long as
lincoln and i so like lincoln and i
could do some more blues when he wasn't
around and there's just so many places
to explore and when
i i gotta say if you're on skis
and you go to a place that doesn't allow
snowboarders it
that's a that's not going to happen much
longer it's just economically there's no
way they're going to keep outline
snowboarding at deer valley there's too
many grandkids that the grandparents
want them to go skiing with them if
they've gotten until 2022 without
allowing eric was even saying there's no
way this will continue
well they're holding out they're holding
out big time but it's it is a entirely
different experience because
snowboarders are they're punks they're
punks they're they're teenagers they're
20
and they're they're knuckle-dragging and
they're like boot-dragging and they're
like taking up space and they got this
big blind spot and they're tearing up
the slopes and like i'm becoming
hoity-toity about it
but i'll tell you i mean it definitely
feels different because it was a
different crowd it's an it's an older
crowd it's a more docile crowd uh it's a
less stinky crowd
but i will go back to snowboarding i was
like lincoln you got to learn to
snowboard too and i i can definitely get
back on that i don't know what my pelvis
will do yeah i think i ultimately had
more fun snowboarding but i just don't
think i can do it i i think that the the
stress on the back is just too much i
mean that's why i switched yeah but the
stress on the knees and with torah
ligaments
so there you go it's like it can still
yeah
you can make an argument that
snowboarding is is i'd rather say i'd
rather sacrifice the knees than the back
though okay
see i think i got into skiing because
you started scaring me about that but
like i actually don't know if for me
snowboarding it may be a better choice
but i want to be able to go both ways
you know okay
the airbnb we stayed at every morning
when we woke up i it was like this this
like
all the windows or like two stories of
windows like facing the ski slopes
across the valley at night i could i
would sit there at the windows and see
um of course the slopes close at like
four o'clock but like at midnight you
can see the groomers like those big snow
cats coming down like they got their
headlights on and it looks like
falling stars just like traversing the
slopes and it was a full moon it was a
beautiful it was a beautiful
beautiful night
and then
um the next morning
i get up and in our backyard
there's a herd of elk
grazing really i heard a freaking help
never seen an elk in person grazing
right there and they came in elk they
came back every morning the first
morning the dogs were going ballistic
and and i was like
there's some there's some fluffy deer
out there
and chrissy's like i don't think that's
a deer well i was like what were they
like the size of horses yeah because
they're very big oh yeah
yeah and then chris is like
i was like well i
you know what i think it's an elk she
looked it up and sure enough rhett and
it was elk
sitting right out there just grazing
taking little little dumps
at the edge of my backyard that then the
dogs would go out there and investigate
afterwards and jasper would probably i
did not let the dogs out while the elk
were there i didn't know what would
happen get kicked in the face or
something like that i doubt it they
probably would run so
um the final highlight one night we
christy booked she was like we're going
to the viking yurt
i was like what
a yurt is like what is that like a big
tent
she's like yeah
i was like
she's like it's on the top of a mountain
and you're going to ride in a sleigh to
get there
and so it's like we show up and there's
this one of those snow cats you know
that like
pulls the stuff that grooms the mountain
like with the treads and stuff that can
go straight up the mountain
it was pulling this like
sl sled type thing that would hold
20 people
and so like all
the of us and what city was arrested
this is in park city this is on the park
city slope okay because they have a
thing like you can go to the rails it's
a restaurant
yeah it's a restaurant so you so you get
on the sleigh pulled by the snow cat and
you go up the mountain christy who
wasn't skiing the slopes we're like
telling her oh we were skiing the slope
we were like we were here today and just
like so she got to experience the slopes
even though she didn't want to ski and
we go up there again it was a full moon
by the time we get up there to this like
uh tent that will hold like individual
tables enough for like 20 people so
pretty small
and um it was a six course meal
i was like man i'm not used to sitting
down eating a six course meal i'm not
used to eating for two hours i'm not
french
yeah
it was awesome though and we get up
there to the top and uh it turns out we
had skied all around that thing we
didn't even notice that there was a yurt
right there was it a viking
it was viking themed we wore um
uh viking helmets for some photo ops
yeah did uh was it like eating with your
hands was it like he didn't go that far
now uh we still
spoke english
and um
one was uh no one was killed and no one
was making love in the yurt in front of
everybody and nobody there weren't
people that's what i think about like i
watched the show vikings and that's
that's the thing i remember is that they
were making love
in the under the bear skins in front of
everybody
right but were there people like nobody
looked like vikings serving and stuff
there no they were they served us some
grog
which was like a spiced
i don't know
wassel
okay some sort of a waffle drink i would
call it they called it grog
they kind of frowned when i said oh you
mean is this k this tastes like a waffle
and then they spiked it and we had a
good night came back down the sleigh
down
took the sleigh back down i don't when
you take this lay down there is it not
being pulled anymore it's just just free
falls let you go on the on the way up
man
there were all these groups of like
like
utah people
with skis
going up the mountain to get to the yurt
no just like this is what they do on a
thursday night cross-country skiing well
it turns out it's not cross country it's
uphill skiing they were going up the
hill i was like how does this happen i
had to ask eric he was like oh it's
called skinning and then he went out and
he got he was like here are my skins
it's like phillip you put your you put
this skin over your ski
and then
if you rub it one way it's like you know
those pillows you rub and it's smooth
one way and you rub it the other way and
it's like dark you push it forward it
grabs a slope and you can go yeah it's
fabric and it's called skinning maybe
make sure you put those on my guess is
that they would like put elk skin on
there back in the day
and if you rub the the hairs if you go
against the grain you can climb up the
mountain
so there's people like only rubbing elk
one way uphilling out alpine touring or
skinny and they probably disconnect
their heel
yep the heel is disconnected
and then you can um once you hike up
then you turn around you get to the top
you take your skins off and you readjust
your boots and you ski back down
i mean
i'm that seems pretty cool it's another
thing and then you got yes a workout
like i i really like park city man i
really like it i i
i think i'm gonna be going back i mean
in the summer time there's mountain
biking that you know everything converts
to being still an outdoor play place for
mountain bike you know eric's definitely
trying to talk talked me into like
getting a place in park city i'm like
well let's not get ahead of our city
mountain bike
yeah
yeah
so
i don't know positive report on park
city man
i'm glad you didn't get hurt i didn't
get hurt
so that you gotta you got i mean you
gotta push it a little harder you gotta
get a ralph in your life
that takes you to the top of the
mountains and just nope
throws you into a blizzard and then you
have to beg the person to let you go
back down the lift
that turns you into a man
not if you go back down on the lift well
they didn't let me
if you had to do it again would you have
gone down the lift uh
well no i don't have to do it again i'm
glad i didn't go down the list you were
time traveled back to that moment where
you decided to not go back down because
you have gone down the lift no it turns
out it ended up being fine i thought
that's when you hurt your knee no no i
hurt my knee on the green oh
yeah you can it doesn't matter the color
of the
the uh slope doesn't indicate the
is it my record today necessarily um
wreck baby wreck baby one two three four
i'll wrap it up with um
found another music podcast
you know i'm into uh classic hip-hop
music podcasts
more of them are coming out of the
woodwork it's like
it's it's kind of like the the founding
fathers of hip-hop are coming to grips
with
the fact that like hey we're still here
and we're
we're
we're holding the
we're holding a mantle for what we've
built
and for for what's blown up to what it
is today
and strengthening the ties
um
between
early hip-hop and what it's become today
and so that they can be appreciated
and in some ways if still relevant i
think the perfect example of that if
you're into what i'm saying is
uh
the bridge 50 years of hip hop
is hosted by nas and miss info lots of
good episodes that i've enjoyed
ice cube
dj jazzy jeff
uh
reverend ron
from run dmc
uh
listened to cyprus hill recently these
are all like
throwback episodes there's some he also
interviews core day
so he's got some he's got some new but
nas you know he's a he's hip-hop legend
so he can get people to come on his show
that won't do any other podcasts like
chuck d
and um so it's if you're into that like
i am it's really cool and if you're not
you wouldn't like it the bridge
it's a spotify original
so it's only on spotify i guess
have at it
and we'll see you next week oh you
weren't ready for that
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]